[Musique]
avec 14000 900 cas de dengue déclaré sur
l'île depuis le début de l'année
l'épidémie ne cesse de progresser dans
ce contexte le département de la réunion
a procédé à une distribution de kits
anti moustiques aux assistants et
accueillants familiaux c'est l'ouest qui
en a bénéficié en premier étant l'une
des zones les plus touchées
l'objectif de cette opération est de les
doter en fait ce public de moyens de
protection aussi bien face à la finlande
que face à ce kit anti moustiques
qu'ovide est composé de d'une trentaine
de masques ffp2 d'un diffuseur prise
murale électrique d'une lotion anti
moustiques et de vie sachez
espira pour la pour les accueillants
familiaux nous avons sur deux jours 90
personnes environ et les assistants nous
avons 150 personnes sur trois jours pour
l'ouest les gens évidemment ils sont
satisfaits sur moi qui le déplacement le
clip c'est qu'ils ont compris
l'importance de cette distribution de
kits pour la santé des réunionnais en
général les bénéficiaires de ces kits
anti moustiques sont très satisfaits de
cette initiative
j'avais fragile donc si on gagne quand
la dengue mais parce que nos besoins des
habitants des hauts de l'aude a donc là
où il fait frais lennar l'humidité d'eau
que c'est bien de pouvoir pour protéger
les personnes et pour moi ne voit que le
département est sans lien nous j'ai déjà
bien et voilà des kits anti moustiques
dans lesquels on pouvait également
trouver des masques ffp2 car si la
dengue est très présente dans notre
département locaux vides 19 continue
aussi à toucher la population
[Musique]